good evening from belmont university in
nashville tennessee i'm kristen welker
of
nbc news and i welcome you to the final
2020 presidential debate
between president donald j trump and
former vice president joe biden
tonight's debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
it is conducted under health and safety
protocols
designed by the commission's health
security advisor
the audience here in the hall has
promised to remain silent
no cheers boos or other interruptions
except
right now as we welcome to the stage
former vice president joe biden
and president donald j trump
thank you and i do want to say a very
good evening
to both of you this debate will cover
six major topics
at the beginning of each section each
candidate will have two minutes
uninterrupted
to answer my first question the debate
commission will then turn on
their microphone only when it is their
turn to answer
and the commission will turn it off
exactly when the two minutes have
expired
after that both microphones will remain
on but on behalf of the voters i'm going
to ask you to please speak one at a time
the goal is for you to hear each other
and for the american people to hear
every word of what you both have to say
and so with that if you're ready let's
start
and we will begin with the fight against
the coronavirus president trump the
first question is for you
the country is heading into a dangerous
new phase more than forty thousand
americans are in the hospital tonight
with covid
including record numbers here in
tennessee and since the two of you last
shared a stage sixteen thousand
americans have died from covid
so please be specific how would you lead
the country during this
next stage of the coronavirus crisis two
minutes uninterrupted
so as you know 2.2 million people
modeled out were expected to die we
closed up
the greatest economy in the world in
order to fight
this horrible disease that came from
china it's a worldwide pandemic
it's all over the world you see the
spikes in europe and many other places
right now
if you notice the mortality rate is down
85 percent the excess mortality rate is
way down and much lower than almost any
other country
and we're fighting it and we're fighting
it hard there is a spike there was a
spike in florida
and it's now gone there was a very big
spike in texas
it's now gone there was a very big spike
in arizona it's now gone
and there are some spikes and surges and
other places they will soon be gone
we have a vaccine that's coming it's
ready it's
going to be announced within weeks and
it's going to be delivered we have
operation warp speed which is the
military is going to distribute the
vaccine
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic
i guess they would call it some people
could say it was a cure but
i was in for a short period of time and
i got better very fast or i wouldn't be
here tonight
and now they say i'm immune whether it's
four months or a lifetime nobody's been
able to say that but
i'm immune more and more people are
getting better we have a problem that's
a worldwide problem this is a worldwide
problem
but i've been congratulated by the heads
of many countries on what we've been
able to do
with the if you take a look at what
we've done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else and in particular
ventilators we're now making ventilators
all over the world thousands and
thousands a month distributing them all
over the world
it will go away and as i say we're
rounding the turn we're rounding the
corner it's going away
okay former vice president biden to you
how would you lead the country out of
this crisis
you have two minutes uninterrupted 220
000
americans dead if you hear nothing else
i say tonight
hear this anyone is responsible for not
taking control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain
as president of the united states of
america we're in a situation where there
are a thousand
deaths a day now a thousand deaths a day
and there are over 70 000 new
cases per day compared to
what's going on in europe as the new
england medical journal said they're
starting from a very
low rate we're starting from a very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
two hundred thousand americans dead
be timed between now and the end of the
year if we just wore
these masks the president's own advisors
have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan no comprehensive plan
what i would do is make sure we have
everyone encouraged to wear a mask
all the time i would make sure we move
in the direction of rapid testing
investing in rapid testing i would make
sure that we
set up national standards as to how to
open up schools and open up businesses
so they can be safe
and give them the wherewithal the
financial resources to be able to do
that
we're in a situation now where the new
england medical journal one of the
serious most serious journals in the
in the whole world said for the first
time ever
that this the way this president has
responded to this crisis
has been absolutely tragic and so folks
i will take care of this i will end this
i will make sure we have a plan
president trump i'd like to follow up
with you and your comments you talked
about taking a therapeutic i assume
you're referencing
regeneron you also said a vaccine will
be coming within weeks
yes is that a guarantee is no it's not a
guarantee but it will be by the end of
the year but i think it has a good
chance there are two companies i think
within a matter of weeks
and it will be distributed very quickly
you tell us which companies
johnson johnson is doing very well
moderner is doing very well
pfizer is doing very well and we have
numerous others
then we also have others that we're
working on very closely with other
countries in particular
europe let me follow up with you because
this is new information you have said a
vaccine is coming soon within weeks now
your own officials say
it could take well into 2021 at the
earliest for enough americans to get
vaccinated
and even then they say the country will
be wearing masks and distancing
into 2022. is your timeline realistic
no i think my timeline is going to be
more accurate i don't know that they're
counting on the military the way i do
but we have our generals lined up one in
particular that's the
head of logistics and this is a very
easy distribution for him he's ready to
go as soon as we have the vaccine
and we expect to have a hundred million
vials as soon as we have the vaccine
he's ready to go vice president biden
your reaction and just 40
percent of americans say they would
definitely agree to take a coronavirus
vaccine
if it was approved by the government
what steps would you take to give
americans confidence
in a vaccine if it were approved make
sure it's totally
transparent have the scientists of the
world see it
know it look at it go through all the
processes and by the way
he's this is the same fellow told you
this is going to end by easter
last time this is the same fellow who
told you that don't worry we're going to
end this by
the summer we're about to go into a dark
winter a dark winter
and he has no clear plan and there's no
prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year
president trump your reaction he says
you have no plan to have a dark winter
and
at all we're opening up our country
we've learned and studied and understand
the disease
which we didn't at the beginning when i
closed and banned
china from coming in heavily infected
and then ultimately europe
but china was in january months later he
was saying i was xenophobic i did it too
soon now he's saying oh
i should have uh i should have you know
moved quicker but he didn't move quicker
he was months behind me
many months behind me and frankly he ran
the h1
n1 swine flu and it was a total disaster
far less lethal
but it was a total disaster had that had
this kind of
numbers 700 000 people would be dead
right now but it was a far less lethal
disease look his own person who
ran that for him who as you know was his
uh chief of staff said it was
catastrophic it was horrible we didn't
know what we were doing
now he comes up and he tells us how to
do this also
everything that he said about the way
every single move that he said we should
make
that's what we've done we've done all of
it but he was way behind us
vice president biden your response my
response is he is xenophobic but not
because he shut down
access from china and he did it late
after 40 countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in
there
in china trying to get to wuhan to
determine what exactly the source was
what did the president say in january
he said no he said this is he's being
transparent
the president of china is being
transparent we owe more debt of
gratitude we ought to we have to thank
him
and and then what happened was we
started talking about using the defense
act
to make sure we go out and get whatever
is needed out there to protect people
and again i go back to this he had
nothing he did
virtually nothing and then he gets out
of the hospital
and he talks about where this is oh
don't worry
it's all going to be over soon come on
there's not another serious scientist in
the world who thinks it's going to be
over soon
president trump your reaction over soon
i say we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock himself up i don't know he's
obviously made a lot of money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that
and kirsten every every meeting i had
every meeting i had and i'd meet a lot
of families including gold star families
and military families
every meeting i had and i had to meet
them i had to it would be horrible to
have canceled everything
i said you know this is dangerous and
you catch it and you know i caught it i
learned a lot
i learned a lot great doctors great
hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nature we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have a nation
and of course the cdc has said young
people can get sick with covet 19 and
can pass it
vice president biden i want to talk
broadly about strategy
though you just respond to that 30
seconds please and i have a question
no number one he says that we're uh you
know we're learning to live with it
people are learning to die with it you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over to try to touch their
out of habit where their wife or husband
was is gone
learning to live with it come on we're
dying with it
because he's never said he said it's
dangerous when's the last time is it
really dangerous still
are we dangerous you tell the people
it's dangerous now what should they do
about the danger
and you say i take no responsibility let
me talk about your
excuse me i think i take full
responsibility
it's not my fault that it came here it's
china's fault and you know what it's not
joe's fault that it came here either
it's china's fault they kept it from
going into the rest of china for the
most
part but they didn't keep it from coming
out to the world including europe and
ourselves
vice president biden the fact is that
when we knew it was coming
when it hit what happened what did the
president say
he said don't worry it's going to go
away be gone by easter don't worry the
warm weather don't worry maybe inject
bleach he said he was kidding when he
said that a lot of people thought it was
serious
a whole range of things the president
has said even today
he thinks we are in control we're about
to lose 200 000 more people
president trump look perhaps just to
finish this
i was kidding on that but just to finish
this
when i closed he said i shouldn't have
closed
and that went on for months what nancy
pelosi said the same thing she was
dancing on the streets in chinatown in
san francisco
but when i closed he said this is a
terrible thing you xenophobic i think he
called me racist even
and because i was closing it to china
now he says i should have closed it
earlier
it just joe it doesn't i didn't say
either of those things
you certainly did i talked about a
xenophobia in a different context it
wasn't about
closing the border to chinese coming to
the united states all right i want to
talk about both of your different
strategies to handle i thought
i shouldn't have closed the border
that's obvious
is that do you want to respond to that
quickly vice president okay let's talk
about your different
strategies toward dealing with this mr
vice president you suggested you would
support new shutdowns if scientists
recommended it what do you say to
americans who are fearful that the cost
of shutdowns the impact on the economy
the higher rates of hunger depression
domestic and substance abuse
outweighs the risk of exposure to the
virus what i would say
is i'm going to shut down the virus not
the country it's his ineptitude that
caused the buyer to cause the country to
have to shut down in large part
why businesses have gone under why
schools are closed why so many people
have lost their
living and why they're concerned those
other concerns are real that's why
he should have been instead of in a sand
trap in his golf course he should have
been negotiating
with nancy pelosi and the rest of the
democrats and republicans about
what to do about the acts they were
passing for billions of dollars to make
sure people had the capacity but you
haven't ruled out more shutdowns
well no i i'm not shutting down the
night but there are look
they need standards the standard is if
you have a reproduction rate in a
community
that's above a certain level everybody
says slow
up more social distancing do not open
bars and do not open gymnasiums do not
open until you get this under control
under more control but when you do open
give the people the capacity to be able
to open and have the capacity
to do it safely for example schools
schools they need a lot of money to open
they need to
deal with ventilation systems they need
to deal with smaller classes
more teachers more pods and he's refused
to support that money
or at least up to now let's talk about
schools president trump i think we have
to respond if i might
please and then i have a follow-up thank
you and i appreciate that look all he
does is talk about shutdowns but forget
about him
his democrat governors cuomo and new
york you look at what's going on in
california you look at pennsylvania
north carolina
democrats democrats all they're shut
down so tight
and they're dying they're dying and he
supports all these people
all he talks about is shutdowns no we're
not going to shut down and we have to
open our schools
and it's like as an example i have a
young son he also
tested positive by the time i spoke to
the doctor the second time he was fine
it just went away
young people i guess it's their immune
system let me follow up with you
president trump you've demanded schools
open in person and insist they can do it
safely but just yesterday
boston became the latest city to move
its public school system entirely online
after a coronavirus spike what is your
message to parents who worry
that sending their children to school
will endanger not only their kids but
also their teachers and families
i want to open the schools the
transmittal rate to the teachers is
very small but i want to open the
schools we have to open our country
we're not going to have a country
you can't do this we can't keep this
country close this is a
massive country with a massive economy
people are losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it often the cure
cannot be worse
than the problem itself that's what's
happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country if
one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
vice president biden you're simply not
true
we ought to be able to walk and chew gum
at the same time we ought to be able to
safely
open but when they need resources to
open
you need to be able to for example if
you're going to open a business
have social distancing within the
business you need to have if you have a
restaurant you need to have
plexiglas dividers so people cannot
infect one another you need to be in a
position where you can take
testing rapidly and know whether a
person is
in fact infected you need to be able to
trace you need to be able to provide
all the resources that are needed to do
this and that is not
inconsistent with saying that
what we're going to make sure that we
open safely and by the way
all you teachers out there not that many
of you are going to die so don't worry
about it
so don't worry about it come on
president trump let me follow up with
you quickly
i will say this if you go and look at
what's happened to new york
it's a ghost town it's a ghost town and
when you talk about plexiglass these are
restaurants that are dying
these are businesses with no money
putting a plexiglass is unbelievably
expensive
and it's not the answer i mean you're
going to sit there in a cubicle
wrapped around with plastic it's these
are businesses that are dying joe you
can't do that to people
you just can't take a look at new york
and what's happened to my
wonderful city for for so many years i
loved it it was vibrant it's dying
everyone's leaving
new york take a look that's what new
york has done in terms of
turning the curve down in terms of the
number of people dying
and i don't look at this in terms of the
way he does blue states and red states
they're all the united states
and look at the states that are having
such a spike in
the coronavirus they're the red states
they're the states in the midwest
of the states in the upper midwest
that's where the spike is occurring
significantly
but they're all americans they're all
americans and what we have to do is say
wear these masks number one make sure we
get the help that the businesses need
that has
monies already been passed to do that
it's been out there since
the beginning of the summer and
nothing's happened
president new york has lost more than 40
000 people eleven thousand people in
nursing
president trump spike take a look at
what's happening
in pennsylvania where they've had it
closed take a look at what's happening
with your friend
in michigan where her husband's the only
one allowed to do anything
it's been like a prison now it was just
ruled unconstitutional
take a look at north carolina they're
having spikes
and they've been closed and they're
getting killed financially
we can't let that happen joe you can't
let that happen
we have to open up and we understand the
disease
we have to protect our seniors we have
to protect our elderly we have to
protect
especially our seniors with heart
problems and diabetes problems
and we will protect we have the best
testing in the world by far
that's why we have so many cases let me
follow up with you before we move on to
our next section president trump this
week you called dr anthony fauci the
nation's best known infectious disease
expert
a disaster you described him and other
medical experts as quote
idiots if you're not listening to them
who are you listening to
i'm listening to all of them including
anthony i get along very well with
anthony but
he did say don't wear masks he did say
as you know this is not going to be a
problem
i think he's a democrat but that's okay
he said this is not going to be a
problem
we are not going to have a problem at
all when joe says that
i said anthony fauci said and others and
many others and i'm not
knocking him a lot nobody knew look
nobody knew what this thing was nobody
knew where it was coming from what it
was
we've learned a lot but anthony said
don't wear masks now he wants to wear
masks
anthony also said if you look back exact
words here's his exact words
this is no problem this is going to go
away soon so he's allowed to make
mistakes
he happens to be a good person vice
president biden your response quickly
and then we're going to move on to the
next section our response is that think
about what the president knew in january
and didn't tell the american people
he was told this was a serious virus
that spread in the air
and it was much worse than much worse
than the flu
he went on record and said to one of
your colleagues
recorded that in fact he knew how
dangerous it was but he didn't want to
tell us
he didn't want to tell us because he
didn't want us to panic he didn't want
americans don't panic he panicked but
guess what in the meantime we find out
in the new york times the other day that
in fact
his folks went to wall street and said
this is a really dangerous thing
and a memo out of that meeting not from
his administration
but from some of the brokers said sell
short because we've got to get moving
it's a dangerous problem well this is
i'm going to give you 30 seconds to
respond and then
the wall street i don't know somebody
went to wall street you're the one that
takes all the money from wall street i
don't take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could raise so much more
money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
i could call the heads of wall street
the heads of every company in america
i would blow away every record but i
don't want to do that
because it puts me in a bad position and
then you bring up wall street you
shouldn't be bringing up wall street
because you're the one that takes the
money from wall street not me
i could blow away your records that like
you wouldn't believe we don't need money
we have plenty of money in fact
we beat hillary clinton with a tiny
fraction of the money that she was able
all right gentlemen
don't tell me about this average
contribution 43 all right we're going to
move on to our next section which is
national security
and i do want to start with the security
of our elections and some breaking news
from overnight just last night
top intelligence officials confirmed
again that both russia and iran
are working to influence this election
both countries have obtained
u.s voter registration information these
officials say
and iran sent intimidating messages to
florida voters
this question goes to you mr vice
president what would you do to put an
end to this threat you have two minutes
uninterrupted i made it clear
and i ask everyone else to take the
pledge i made it clear that any
country no matter who it is that
interferes in american elections
will pay a price they will pay
a price it's been overwhelmingly clear
this election i won't
even get into the last one this election
that russia has been involved
china has been involved to some degree
and now we learn that
that that iran is involved they
will pay a price if i'm elected they're
interfering with american
sovereignty that's what's going on right
now they're interfering with american
sovereignty
and to the best of my knowledge i don't
think the president said anything to
putin about it
i don't think he's stalking them a lot i
don't think he said a word i don't know
why he hadn't said a word to putin about
it
and i don't know what he has recently
said if anything to the iranians my
guess is he'd probably be more outspoken
with regard to the iranians but the
point is this folks
we are in a situation where we have
foreign company
countries trying to interfere in the
outcome of our election his old
own national security adviser told him
that what is happening with his
buddy well i won't guess well i will his
buddy
rudy giuliani he's being used as a
russian pawn
he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then what happens
nothing happens
and then you find out that everything is
going on here
about russia is wanting to make sure
that i do not get elected to the next
presidential states
because they know i know them and they
know
me i don't understand why this president
is unwilling to take on putin
when he's actually paying bounties to
kill american soldiers in afghanistan
when he's engaged in activities that are
trying to destabilize
all of nato i don't know why he doesn't
do it but it's worth
asking the question why isn't that being
done
any country interferes with us will in
fact pay a price
because they're affecting our
sovereignty president trump
same question to you let me let me ask
the question you're gonna have two
minutes to respond for two elections in
a row now there has been substantial
interference from foreign adversaries
what would you do in your next term to
put an end to this two minutes
let me respond to the first part as joe
answered joe got three and a half
million dollars from russia
and it came through putin because he was
very friendly with the
former mayor of moscow and it was the
mayor of moscow's wife and
you got three and a half million dollars
your family got three and a half million
dollars and
you know someday you're gonna have to
explain why did you get three to half i
never got any money from russia i don't
get money from russia
now about your thing last night i knew
all about that
and through john who was john rutlef who
was fantastic dni
he said the one thing that's common to
both of them
they both want you to lose because there
has been nobody tougher to russia
with between the sanctions nobody
tougher than me on russia
between the sanctions between all of
what i've done with nato you know i've
got the nato countries to put up
an extra 130 billion going to 420
billion dollars a year
that's to guard against russia i sold
while he was selling pillows and sheets
i sold tank busters to ukraine there has
been nobody
tougher than on russia than donald trump
and i'll tell you they were so bad they
took over the
the submarine port you remember that
very well
during your term during you and barack
obama
they took over a big part of what should
have been ukraine you handed it to him
but you were getting a lot of money from
russia they were paying you a lot of
money
and they probably still are but now with
what came out today
it's even worse all of the emails the
emails the horrible emails of the kind
of money that you were raking in you and
your family
and joe you were vice president when
some of this was happening
and it should have never happened and i
think you owe an explanation to the
american people
why is it somebody just had a news
conference a little while
ago who was essentially supposed to work
with you and your family
but what he said was damning and
regardless of me i think you have to
clean it up and talk to the american
people maybe you can do it right now
vice president biden you may respond
security i have not taken a penny from
any foreign source
ever in my life we learned that this
president
paid 50 times the tax in china has a
secret bank account
with china does business in china
and in fact is talking about me taking
money
i have not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever ever number one number two
this is a president i have released all
of my tax returns
22 years go look at them 22 years of my
tax return
you have not released the single
solitary year of your tax return
what are you hiding why are you
unwilling the foreign countries are
paying you
a lot russia's paying you a lot china's
painting a lot
on your hotels and all your businesses
all around the country
all around the world and china's
building a new road to a new
a golf course you have overseas so
what's going on here why don't release
your tax return or stop talking about
corruption
president trump your response first of
all i called my accountants
underwrote it i'm going to release them
as soon as we can i want to do it
and it'll show how successful how great
this company is but
much more importantly than that people
were saying 750
i asked them a week ago i said what did
i pay
they said sir you prepaid tens of
millions of dollars i prepaid my tax
tens over the last number of years tens
of millions of dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think it's an
estimate they think i may have to pay
tax
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
that did your account nobody tell
you that excuse me and it wasn't written
whenever they write this
they keep talking about 750 which i
think is a filing fee
but let me just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from
russia you made three and a half million
dollars joe
and your son gave you they even have a
statement that
we have to give 10 percent to the big
man you're the big man i think
i don't know maybe you're not but you're
the big man i think
your son said we have to give 10 to the
big man joe what's that all about
it's terrible all right gentlemen i want
to ask you both some questions about all
of this but
i'm going to let you both respond very
quickly you just said you spoke to your
accountant about potentially releasing
your taxes did he tell you when you can
release them do you
have this deadline for when you're going
to release it i get married
worse than the tea party got treated
because i have a lot of people in there
deep down in the irs they treat me
horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until i decided to run for
president
i get treated very badly by the irs very
unfairly
but we had a deal all done as soon as
we're completed with the deal i want to
release it
but i have paid millions and millions of
dollars
and i it's worse than paying i paid in
advance it's called
pre-paying your taxes i paid in it i
want to ask you both about questions
regarding
your potential foreign entanglements and
questions that have been raised to give
you both a chance to talk about this
more broadly
respond very quickly and then i'll get
to my question why did
he's been saying this for four years
show us
just show us stop playing around you've
been saying for four years you're gonna
release your taxes
nobody knows mr president what they do
know is you're not
paying your taxes or you're paying taxes
that are so low
when last time he said what he paid he
said i only pay that little because i'm
smart
i know how to game the system come on
come on folks so president trump and
then i want to get to two questions to
both of you
i was put through a phony witch hunt
for three years it started
before i even got elected they spied on
my campaign
no president should ever have to go
through what i went through let me just
say this mueller and 18 angry democrats
and fbi agents all over the place spent
48 million dollars
they went through everything i had
including my tax returns
and they found absolutely no collusion
and nothing wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spent 1
million on youtube i could find plenty
wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken
i mean your brother made money in iraq
millions of dollars
your other brother made a fortune and
it's all through you joe and they say
you get some of it
and you do live very well you have
houses all over the place you live very
well
all right gentlemen let me just ask some
questions about all of this broadly vice
president biden there have been
questions about the work your son has
done in china
and for a ukrainian energy company when
you were vice president in retrospect
was anything about those relationships
inappropriate or unethical
nothing was unethical here's what the
deal
with regard to ukraine we had this whole
question about whether or not because he
was on the board i later learned of a
barisma
a company that somehow i had done
something wrong
yet every single solitary person when he
was going through his impeachment
testifying under oath who worked for him
said i did my job
impeccably i carried out u.s policy
not one single solitary thing was out of
line not a single thing
number one number two the guy who got in
trouble in ukraine was this guy
trying to bribe the ukrainian government
to say something negative about me
which they would not do and did not do
because it never
ever ever happened my son has not made
money in terms of this thing about uh
what are you talking about
china i have not had the only guy made
money from china
is this guy he's the only one nobody
else has made money from china
no president let me ask my question to
you
could i just one one thing very quickly
his son didn't have a job for a long
time
was sadly no longer in the military
service i won't get into that
and he didn't have a job as soon as he
became vice president
barisma not the best look not the best
reputation in the world
i hear they paid him 183 000
a month listen to this 183
and they gave him a three million dollar
upfront payment all right and he had no
energy i'm gonna let the vice president
respond to that quickly and then i need
to get to a question to you very no
basis for that everybody investigated
that no one said anything he did was
wrong in ukraine
okay president trump this is for you
since you took office you've never
divested from your business you've
personally promoted your properties
abroad
a report this week which was referenced
does indicate that your company has a
bank account in china
so how can voters know that you don't
have any foreign conflicts of interest
i have many bank accounts and they're
all listed and they're all over the
place i mean
i was a businessman doing business the
bank account you're referring to
which is everybody knows about it it's
listed the bank account was in
2013. that's what it was it was opened
into
it was closed in 2015 i believe
and then i decided because i was going
to do i was thinking about doing a deal
in china like
millions of other people i was thinking
about it and i decided i'm not going to
do it
didn't like it i decided not to do it
had an account open
and i closed it okay excuse me and then
unlike him where he's vice president and
he does business
i then decided to run for president
after that that was before
so i closed it before i even ran for
president
let alone became president big
difference he is
the vice president of the united states
and his son his brother
and his other brother are getting rich
they're like a vacuum cleaner they're
sucking
thank you move on i do want to ask you
uh vice president biden about china
let's talk about china more broadly
there have of course president trump has
said that they should pay for
not being fully transparent in regards
to the coronavirus
if you were president would you make
china pay and please be specific what
would that look like
what i'd make china do is play by the
international rules
not like he has done he has caused the
deficit of china to go up
not down with china up not down
we are making sure that in order to do
business in china you have to give all
your intellectual property you have to
get a
have a partner in china is 51 percent we
would not do that at all
number one number two we're in a
situation where china would have to play
by the rules internationally as well
when i met with xi that and uh when i
was still vice president he said we're
setting up air identification zones in
the
in the south china sea you can't fly
through them i said we're going to fly
through them we just flew b-52
b-1 bombers through it we're not going
to pay attention they have to play
by the rules and what's he do he
embraces
guys like the thugs like in north korea
and and and the chinese president and
putin and others
and he pokes his fingers now of all of
our friends all of our allies
we make up only we're 25
25 of the world's economy we need to be
having the rest of our friends
with us saying to china these are the
rules you play by them or you're going
to pay the price for not paying by them
economically that's the way i will run
it and that's what we did
an upholding steel tariffs and a range
of other things when we were president
and vice president
all right let's talk about north korea
let's just mean i have to respond to
that
okay very quickly and then we're going
to invite you to three and a half
dollars from chinatown
after spending ten minutes in office and
being in air force two
number one number two there's a very
strong
email talking about your family wanting
to make
10 million dollars a year for
introductions president trump on china
policy though what's nobody
are you going to do what specifically
are you going to do
to make china pay you've said you're
going to pay china
they're paying billions and billions of
dollars i just gave 28 billion dollars
new sanctions
i just gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers taxpayers china
that's what taxpayers money yeah you
know the taxpayers it's called china
china paid 28 billion and you know what
they did to pay it joe
they devalued their currency and they
also paid up and you know who got the
money our farmers are great farmers
because they were targeted
you never charged them anything also i
charged them 25
on dumped steel because they were
killing our steel industry we were not
going to have a steel index okay
and now we have a steel okay vice
president biden your response please our
response is look
this isn't about there's a reason why
he's
bringing up all this malarkey there's a
reason for it
he doesn't want to talk about the the
substantive issues it's not about his
family and my family
it's about your family and your family
is hurting badly
if you're making less than if you're a
middle-class family
you're getting hurt badly right now
you're sitting at the kitchen table this
morning deciding
well we can't get new tires they're bald
because we have to wait another month or
so
or are we going to be able to pay the
mortgage or who's going to tell her she
can't go back to
to community college they're the
decisions you're making
in the middle class families like i grew
up in scranton and claim on
they're in trouble we should be talking
about your families but that's the last
thing he wants to talk about
i want to say i want to talk about north
korea
ten seconds mr president ten seconds
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician when i see
that let's talk about a difficult
politician okay
that's why i got elected let's get off
the subject of china let's talk around
sitting around the table
come on joe you can do better we're
going to talk about north korea now
president trump you've met with north
korean leader kim jong-un
three times you've talked about your
beautiful letters with him you've touted
the fact that there hasn't been a war
or a long-range missile test and yet
north korea recently rolled out its
biggest ever intercontinental ballistic
missile
and continues to develop its nuclear
arsenal do you see that as a betrayal of
the relationship you forged
just 30 seconds here because we need to
get on to the next so when i met with
barack
obama we sat in the white house right at
the beginning had a great conversation
was supposed to be 15 minutes and it was
well over an hour
he said the biggest problem we have with
north is north korea
he indicated we will be in a war with
north korea guess what
it would be a nuclear war and he does
have plenty of nuclear capability
in the meantime i have a very good
relationship with him different kind of
a guy but he probably thinks the same
thing about me
we have a different kind of a
relationship we have a very good
relationship
and there's no war and you know about
two months ago
he broke into a certain area they said
oh there's going to be trouble he said
no they're not
because he's not going to do that and i
was right look instead of being in a war
where millions of people
soul you know is 25 miles away millions
and millions 32 million people in seoul
millions of people would be dead right
now president trump that's 30 seconds
vice president biden to you north korea
conducted four nuclear tests under the
obama administration
why do you think you would be able to
reign in this persistent threat
because i'd make it clear which we were
making clear to china they had to be
part of the deal because here's the re
i made it clear and as a spokesperson
administration when i went to china
that they said why are you moving your
missile defense up so close why are you
moving more forces here why you continue
to do
military maneuvers with south korea i
said because
north korea is a problem and we're going
to continue to do it so we can control
them
we're going to make sure we can control
them and make sure they cannot hurt us
and so if you want to do something about
it step up and help if not
it's going to continue what has he done
he's legitimized north korea
he's talked about his good buddy who's a
thug a thug
and he talks about how we're better off
and they are have much more capable
missiles
able to reach u.s territory much more
easily than ever did before let me
follow up with you
vice president biden you've said you
wouldn't meet with kim jong-un without
preconditions are there any conditions
under which you would meet with him
on the condition that he would agree
that he would be drawing down his
nuclear capacity to get that the korean
peninsula should be nuclear free zone
all right let's move on to american
families they tried
very quickly ten seconds they tried to
meet with him he wouldn't do it
he didn't like obama he didn't like him
he wouldn't do it
okay i gotta give him a picture respond
to that
and that's okay you know what north
korea we're not in a war
we have a good relationship you know
people don't understand having a good
relationship
with leaders of other countries we have
a lot of questions to get to
that's right man we had a good
relationship with hitler before he
in fact invaded europe the rest of
europe come on
dave the reason he would not meet with
president obama is because president
obama said
we're going to talk about
denuclearization we're not going to
legitimize you and we're going to
continue to put stronger and stronger
sanctions on you that's why he wouldn't
meet with us
all right and it didn't move on let's
just go on and talk about it
chris president trump okay left me a
mess
north korea was a mess and in fact if
you remember the first two or three
months questions tonight
it was a very dangerous period in my
first three months before we
sort of worked things out a little bit
there was a very they left us
a mess and obama would be i think the
first to say it was the single biggest
problem he thought
that our country okay let's move on to
american families and the economy on
one of the issues that's most important
to them is health care as you both
know today there was a key vote on a new
supreme court justice amy coney barrett
and health care is at the center of her
confirmation fight
over 20 million americans get their
health insurance through the affordable
care act
it's headed to the supreme court and
your administration mr president
is advocating for the court to overturn
it if the supreme court does overturn
that law
those 20 million americans could lose
their health insurance almost overnight
so what would you do
if those people have their health
insurance taken away you have two
minutes uninterrupted
first of all i've already done something
that nobody thought was possible
through the legislature i terminated the
individual mandate
that is the worst part of obamacare as
we call it
the individual mandate where you have to
pay a fortune for the privilege of
not having to pay for bad health
insurance i terminated
it's gone now it's in court because
obamacare is no good
but then i made a decision run it as
well as you can to my people
great people run it as well as you can i
could have gone the other route and made
everybody very unhappy
they ran it premiums are down
everything's down here's the problem
no matter how well you run it it's no
good what we'd like to do
is terminate it we have the individual
mandate
done i don't know that it's going to
work if we don't win
we will have to run it and we'll have
obamacare but it'll be better run
but it no longer is obamacare because
without the individual mandate
it's much different pre-existing
conditions will always stay
what i would like to do is a much better
health care much better
will always protect people with
pre-existing so i'd like to terminate
obamacare come up with a brand new
beautiful health care
the democrats will do it because
there'll be tremendous pressure on them
and we might even have the house by that
time
and i think we're going to win the house
okay you'll see but i think we're going
to win the house
but come up with a better health care
always protecting people
with pre-existing conditions and one
thing very important we have 180 million
people out there
that have great private health care far
more than we're talking about with
obamacare
joe biden is going to terminate all of
those policies these are people that
love their health care
people that have been successful middle
income people
been successful they have 180
million plants 180 million people
families
under what he wants to do which will
basically be socialized medicine he
won't even have a choice
they want to terminate 180 million plans
we have done an incredible job on health
care
and we're going to do even better okay
vice president biden yes this is for you
your health care plan calls for building
on obamacare so my question is what is
your plan
if the law is ruled unconstitutional by
the supreme court you have two minutes
uninterrupted
what i'm going to do is pass obamacare
with a public option
become biden care the public option is
an option that says that
if you in fact do not have the
wherewithal to be if you qualify for
medicaid
and you do not have the wherewithal then
your state to get medicaid
you automatically are enrolled providing
competition for insurance companies
that's what's going to happen secondly
we're going to make sure we reduce the
premiums and reduce drug prices
by making sure that there's competition
that doesn't exist now by allowing
the medicare to negotiate drug prices
with the insurance companies thirdly
the idea that i want to eliminate
private insurance the reason why i had
such a fight
for with 20 candidates for the
nomination was
i support private insurance that's why
i did not one single person with private
insurance
would lose their insurance under my plan
nor
did they under obamacare they did not
lose their insurance
unless they chose they wanted to go to
something else lastly
we're going to make sure we're in a
situation that we actually
protect pre-existing there's no way he
can protect pre-existing conditions
none zero you can't do it in the ether
he's been talking about this for a long
time there is no he's never come up with
a plan i guess we're going to get
the pre-existing condition planned the
same time we get the infrastructure plan
that we've waited since 17 18 19 and 20.
the fact i still have a few more minutes
i know you're getting anxious
the uh the fact is that the he's already
cost the american people because of his
terrible handling of the covet virus and
economic spillover
10 million people have lost their
private insurance
and he wants to take away 22 million
more people who have it under obamacare
and over 110 million people with
pre-existing conditions
and all the people from covert are going
to have pre-existing conditions
what are they going to do i have a
follow-up for you vice president biden
it relates to something that president
trump said he's accusing you of wanting
socialized medicine what do you say to
people
who have concerns that your health care
plan which includes a government
insurance option takes the country
one step closer to a health care system
run entirely by the government
i say it's ridiculous it's like saying
that you know
where uh the idea that the fact that
there's a public option that people can
choose
that makes it a socialist plan look the
difference between the president i think
health care is not
a privilege it's a right everyone should
have the right to have affordable health
care
and i am very proud of my plan it's
gotten endorsed by
all the major labor unions as well as as
well as a whole range of other people
who in fact are concerned in the medical
field
this is something that's going to save
people's lives and this is going to give
some
people an opportunity an opportunity to
have health care for their children
how many of you home are worried and
rolling around in bed tonight wondering
what in god's name you're going to do if
you get sick because you've lost your
home insurance your your health
insurance your company's gone under
we have to provide health insurance for
people at an affordable rate and that's
what i do
president trump he was here for 47 years
he didn't do it he was now there as vice
president for eight years and it's not
like it was 25 years ago
it was three and three quarters it was
just a little while ago right less than
four years ago
he didn't do anything he didn't do it he
wants socialized medicine and it's not
that he wants it his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders and wants it even
more bernie sanders wants it
the democrats want it you're going to
have socialized medicine just like you
want to with fracking
we're not going to have fracking we're
going to stop fracking we're going to
stop fracking then he goes to
pennsylvania after he gets a nomination
where he got very lucky to get it
and he goes to pennsylvania and he says
oh we're going to have fracking
and you never ask that question and by
the way so far i respect very much the
way you're handling this i have to say
by the way but somebody should ask the
question
you can actually he goes for a year
there will be we have
we have
my response is people deserve to have
affordable health care
period period period period and the
biden care proposal will in fact
provide for that affordable health care
lower premiums what we're going to do is
going to cost some money
it's going to cost over 750 billion over
10 years to do it
and they're going to have lower premiums
you can buy into the better plans
the cheaper plans lower your premiums
deal with
underscore unexpected billing and have
your drug prices drop
significantly he keeps talking about it
he hasn't done a
thing for anybody on health care not a
thing
he's talking about socialized medicine
and when he and and healthcare
when he talks about a public option he's
talking about destroying your medicare
totally destroyed and destroying your
social security and this whole country
will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it in his
state he tried it in a state
his governor was a very liberal governor
they want to make it work
okay let's hear it vice president it
doesn't matter
very confused guy he thinks he's running
against somebody else he's running
against
joe biden i beat all those other people
because i disagreed with them
joe biden he's running against and the
idea that we're in a situation that are
going to destroy medicare
this is the guy that the actuary
medicare said
if in fact at social security if in fact
he continues to
withhold his plan to withhold the tax on
social security
social security will be bankrupt in by
2023
with no way to make up for it this is
the guy who's tried to
cut medicare so no i don't i mean the
idea that donald trump
is lecturing me on social security and
medicare
come on he tried to get rid of he tried
to hurt social security years ago
years ago go back and look at the
records he tried to hurt social security
years ago
all right but this is the guy mr
president i have to move on to the next
question
if i'm elected if he's elected the stock
market will crash
okay let's go to the next question very
quickly
look the idea that the stock market is
booming is his only measure of what's
happening where i come from and scranton
and claymont that people don't live off
of the stock market
just in the uh just in the last three
three years during this crisis
said the the billionaires in this
country made according to the
wall street 700 billion more dollars
700 billion more dollars because that's
his only measure
what happens to the ordinary people out
there what happens to them
let's talk 401ks
he doesn't come from scranton that's
like one of he lived there for a short
period of time before he even knew
we're going to move on and he left and
the people of pennsylvania let me move
on to my next question as of tonight
more than 12 million people are out of
work
and as of tonight 8 million more
americans have fallen into poverty
and more families are going hungry every
day those hit hardest are women
and people of color they see washington
fighting over
a relief bill mr president why haven't
you been able to get them the help they
need 30 seconds here
because nancy pelosi doesn't want to
approve it i do but you're the president
i do but i still have to get
unfortunately that's one of the reasons
i think we're going to take over the
house because
of her nancy pelosi doesn't want to
approve anything because she'd love to
have some victories
on a date called november 3rd nancy
pelosi does not want to approve it
we are ready willing and able to do
something don't forget we've
already approved three plans and it's
gone through including the democrats in
all fairness
this one she doesn't want it's near the
election because she thinks it helps her
politically
i think it hurts her politically all
right mr vice president
the republican leader in in the united
states senate said he can't pass it
he will not be able to pass it he does
not have republican votes
why isn't he talking to his republican
friends let me follow up with you vice
president we made it
because let me ask vice president biden
a question you are the leader of the
democratic party
why have you not pushed the democrats to
get a deal for the american people well
i have and they have pushed it look they
passed this act
all the way back in the beginning of the
summer this is like it's not new
it's been out there this heroes act has
been sitting there
and look at what's happening when i was
in charge of the recovery act with 800
billion dollars
i was able to get 145 billion dollars to
local communities
that have to balance their budgets and
states that have to balance the budget
so then
have to fire fire to have to fire
firefighters
teachers first responders law
enforcement officers so they can keep
their cities and counties running he
will not support that
they have not done a thing for them and
mitch mcconnell said let him go bankrupt
let him go bankrupt come on what's the
matter bill that was passed in the house
was a bailout of badly run high
crime democrat all run by democrats
cities and states
it was a way of getting a lot of money
billions and billions of dollars to
these skates
it was also a way of getting a lot of
money from our people's pockets to
people that come into our country
illegally we were going to take care of
everything for them
and what that does and i'd love to do
that i'd love to help them but what that
does
everybody all over the world will start
pouring into our country we can't do it
this was a way of taking care of them
this was a way of spending on things
that had nothing to do with covet as per
your question
but it was really a big bailout for
badly run
democrat cities and states all right if
i get elected i'm not gonna i'm running
as a proud democrat but i'm gonna be an
american president
i don't see red states in blue states
what i see
is american united states and folks
every single state out there
finds themselves in trouble they're
going to start laying off whether
they're red or blue
cops firefighters first responders
because teachers
because they have to balance their
budget and the founders were smart
they allowed the federal government to
deficit spend to compensate
for the united states of america i want
to talk about the minimum wage gentlemen
mr vice president
we are talking a lot about struggling
small businesses yes
and business owners these days do you
think this is the right time to ask them
to raise the minimum wage you of course
support a 15
federal minimum i do because i think one
of the things we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to bail them out
too
we should be bailing them out now those
small businesses
you've got one in six of them going
under they're not going to be able to
make it back
they pass the a package that allows us
to be able to call ppp money's supposed
to go to help them do everything from
organize how they can deal with their
businesses being open safely
schools how they can make classrooms
smaller how they can hire more teachers
how they can put ventilation systems in
they need the help the businesses as
well as the schools need the help
but this because these guys will not
help them it's not giving them any of
the money
we are going to move on to immigration
but i want to say we have to work for
small businesses
by raising the minimum wage that's not
helping i think it should be a state
option
alabama is different than new york new
york is different from vermont
every state is different it should be a
state app you said we have to help it's
very important
we have to help our small businesses how
are you helping your small businesses
when you're forcing wages
what's going to happen and what's been
proven to happen is when you do that
these small businesses
fire many of their employees you would
consider
raising the federal minimum wage to
fifteen dollars an hour you said
recently you would consider raising the
federal minimum wage to fifteen dollars
an hour
that's still the case and i would
consider it in it to an extent but it
was
really illegal in a second
administration but
not to a level that's going to put all
these businesses out of business
it should be a state option look
everything in different places i know
different places they're all different
some places fifteen dollars is not so
bad
in other places other states fifteen
dollars okay president trump thank you
quick response vice president
two jobs one job be below poverty
people are making six seven eight bucks
an hour these first responders we all
clap for
as they come down the street because
they've allowed us to make it
what's happening they deserve a minimum
wage of fifteen dollars
anything below that puts you below the
poverty level and there is no evidence
that when you raise the minimum wage
businesses go out of business that is
simply not true we're going to talk
about immigration we're going to talk
about immigration now gentlemen
and we're going to talk about families
within this context mr president your
administration
separated children from their parents at
the border at least 4
000 kids you've since reversed your zero
tolerance policy but the united states
can't locate the parents of more than
500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited children
are brought here by coyotes and
lots of bad people cartels and they're
brought here and they used to use them
to get into our country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles of brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through them but how will
you reunite let me just tell you this
with their family they built cages you
know they used to say
i built the cages and then they had a
picture in a certain
newspaper and it was a picture of these
horrible cages
and they said look at these cages
president trump built them
and then it was determined they were
built in 2014.
that was him they built them to reunite
the kids yes we're working on it very
we're trying very hard but a lot of
these kids come out without the parents
they come over through cartels and
through coyotes and through gangs
vice president let me bring you into
this conversation quick response and
then another question to you these 500
plus kids came with parents
they separated them at the border to
make it a disincentive to come to begin
with
they real tough we're really strong and
guess what
they cannot it's not coyotes didn't
bring them over their parents
were with them they got separated from
their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are as a
nation
let me ask you a favor they did it we
changed the policy your response
we did not they built the cages they who
built the cages
let's talk about who built the cages
let's talk about what we're talking
about
what happened parents were ripped their
kids were ripped from their
arms and separated and now they cannot
find over 500 of sets of those parents
and those kids are alone nowhere to go
nowhere to go it's criminal it's
criminal
let me ask listen i will say this they
went down we brought reporters
everything
they are so well taken care of they're
in facilities that were so clean
some of them haven't been reunited but
just ask one question
who built the cages i'd love you to ask
of that who built the cages let me ask
about your immigration policy mr vice
president the obama administration did
fail to deliver
immigration reform which had been a key
promise during the administration it
also presided over record deportations
as well as family detentions at the
border before changing course
so why should voters trust you with an
immigration overhaul now
because we made a mistake it made two it
took too long to get it right
it took too long to get it right i'll be
president united states not vice
president united states
and the fact is i've made it very clear
within 100 days i'm going to send to the
united states congress
a pathway to citizenship for over 11
million undocumented people
and all of those so-called dreamers
those daca kids they're going to be
immediately certified again to be able
to stay
in this country and put on a path to
citizenship the idea that
they are being sent home by this guy and
they want to do that
is they've gone to a country they've
never seen before i can imagine you're
five years old your parents are taking
it across
the rio grande river and is
and it's illegal and you say oh no mom
leave me here i'm not going to go with
you
they've been here many of them are model
citizens over 20 000
were first responders out there taking
care of people during this crisis
we owe them we owe them
christina he had eight years to do what
he said he was going to do
and i've changed without having a
specific
we got rid of catch and release we got
rid of a lot of
horrible things that they put in and
that they lived with
but he had eight years he was vice
president he
did nothing except build cages
to keep children in vice president your
response
the catch and release you know what he's
talking about there if in fact you had
a family came across and they were
arrested
they in fact were given a date to show
up for their hearing
they were released and guess what they
showed up for a hearing
this is the first president in history
united states america that's anybody
seeking asylum has to do it in another
country
that's never happened before in america
that's never happened before in america
you come to the united states and you
make your case that i
seek asylum based on the following on
the following premise
why i deserve it under american law
they're sitting in a squalor on the
other side of the river
president trump your responsibilities it
just shows that he has no
understanding of immigration of the laws
catch and release is a disaster
a murderer would come in a rapist would
come in
a very bad person would come in we would
take their name
we have to release them into our country
and then you say they come back less
than one percent of the people
come back we have to send ice out and
border patrol out to find them we would
say come back
in two years three years we're going to
give you a court case you need perry
mason
we're going to give you a court case
when you say they come back
they don't come back joe they never come
back only the really
i hate to say this but those with the
lowest iq
they might come back okay president
trump let's give vice president biden a
chance to respond and then we're going
to move on to this you don't know
vice president biden your response know
the law what he's telling you is simply
not true
check it out they don't come back check
it out all right let's move but we don't
have to worry about it because they
terminated it so we'd have to worry
about it that's right
yeah 525 kids not knowing where in god's
name they're going to be
and lost their parents go ahead all
right let's talk about our next section
which
is race in america and i want to talk
about the way black and brown americans
experience race in this country part of
that experience is something called
the talk it happens regardless of class
and income parents who feel they have no
choice
but to prepare their children for the
chance that they could be targeted
including by the police for no reason
other than the color of their skin
mr vice president in the next two
minutes i want you to speak directly to
these families
do you understand why these parents fear
for their children
i do i do you know my daughter is a
social worker
and she's all she's written a lot about
this she's a
has a graduate degree from the
university of pennsylvania and social
work
and you know uh one of the reasons why
i ended up working on the east side of
wilmington delaware which is
90 african-american was to learn more
about what was going on what i didn't i
never had to tell my daughter
if she's pulled over make sure she puts
for a
traffic stop put both hands on top of
the wheel and don't reach for the glove
box because someone may shoot you
but a black parent no matter how wealthy
or how poor they are
has to teach their child when you're
walking down the street
don't have a hoodie on when you go
across the street making sure that you
in fact
if you get pulled over yes yes sir no
sir
hands on top of the wheel because you
are in fact the victim whether you're
a person making 300 child of a 300 000
a year person or someone who's on on on
food stamps the fact of the matter is
there is
institutional racism america and we have
always said
we've never lived up to it that we hold
these truths to be self-evident all men
and women are created equal well guess
what
we have never ever lived up to but we've
all
constantly been moving the needle
further and further to inclusion
not exclusion this is the first
president to come along and says that's
the end of that
we're not going to do that anymore we
have to provide for economic opportunity
better education
better health care better access to
schooling
better access to opportunity to borrow
money to start businesses
all the things we can do and i've laid
out a clear plan
as to how to do those things just to
give people a shot
it's about accumulating the ability to
have wealth as well as it is
to be free from violence president trump
same question to you and let me remind
you
of the question i would like you to
speak directly to these families do you
understand why these parents fear for
their children yes i do
and again he's been in government 47
years he never did a thing except in
1994
when he did such harm to the black
community
and they were called and he called them
super predators
and he said that he said it's super
predators
and they could never live that down 1994
your crime bill the super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community than donald trump and if you
look
with the exception of abraham lincoln
possible exception but the exception of
abraham lincoln
nobody has done what i've done criminal
justice reform
obama and joe didn't do it
i don't even think they tried because
they had no chance at doing it
they might have wanted to do it but if
you had to see the arms i had a twist to
get that done
it was not a pretty picture and
everybody knows it including some very
liberal people that
cried in my office they cried in the
oval office two weeks later they're out
saying gee we have to defeat him
criminal justice reform prison reform
opportunity zones with tim scott a great
senator from
south carolina he came in with this
incredible idea for opportunity zones
it's one of the most successful programs
people don't talk about it tremendous
investment is being made biggest
beneficiary
the black and hispanic communities and
then historically black
colleges and universities after three
years of coming to the office
i love some of those guys they were
great they came into the office
and they said i said what are you doing
after three years i said why do you keep
coming back
because we have no funding i said you
don't have to come back every year we
have to come back
because president obama would never give
them long-term funding
and i did 10-year long-term funding and
i gave them more money
than they asked for because they said i
think you need more and i said the only
bad part about this is i may never see
you again because
i got very friendly with them and they
like me and i like them
but i saved historically colleges and
universities
okay and we're going to talk about both
of your records but your response to
that vice president my response to that
is i
never ever said what he accused me of
saying
the fact of the matter is in 2000 though
after the crime bill had been in in
in in in the law for a while this is the
guy who said
the problem with the crime bill there's
not enough people in jail there's not
enough people in jail
and go on my website get the quote the
date when he said it
not enough people he talked about
marauding gangs
young gangs and the people who were
going to maraude our cities
this is a guy who in the central park
five five innocent black kids he
continued to push for making sure
that they got the death penalty none of
them were none of them
were guilty of what the crime of the
crimes they were
suggested look and talk about he granted
he did in fact let 20 people he commuted
20 people sentences
we committed over a thousand people
sentences over a thousand
the very law he's talking about is a law
that in fact
initiated by barack obama and secondly
we're in a situation here where
we the federal prison system was reduced
by
38 000 people under our administration
and one of these things we should be
doing there should be no
no minimum mandatories in the law that's
why i'm offering
20 billion dollars of states to change
their state laws
to eliminate minimum mandatories and set
up drug courts no one should be going to
jail
because they have a drug problem they
should be going to rehabilitation
not to jail we should fundamentally
change the system and that's what i'm
going to do
but why didn't he do it four years ago
why didn't you do that four years ago
even less than that why didn't
i when you were vice president you keep
talking about all these things you're
gonna do
and you're gonna do this but you were
there just a short time ago
and you guys did nothing we did you know
joe i ran because
of you i ran because of barack obama
because you did a poor job
if i thought you did a good job i would
have never run i would have never run
i ran because of you i'm looking at you
now you're a politician
i ran because of you all right vice
president biden your response to that
and then i do have some questions for
both of you well i'll tell you what
i uh i hope he doesn't look at me
because what's happening here is
you know who i am you know who he is
you know his character you know my
character you know our reputations for
honor and telling the truth
i am anxious to have this race i am
anxious to see this
take place i am the character of the
country is on the ballot
our character is on the ballot look at
us closely let me ask some folks
please respond about russia ukraine
china other countries iraq if this is
true
then he's a corrupt politician right so
don't give me the stuff about how you're
this innocent baby
joe they're calling you a corrupt
politician nobody president trump
i want to stay on the issue of race
we're talking about that
from hell president trump we're talking
about race right now and i do want to
stay
on the issue of race president trump i
have to respond to that please
look very quick there are 50 former
national intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the care
four five former heads of the cia both
parties
say what he's saying is a bunch of
garbage nobody believes it except
of his and his good friend rudy gianni
you mean the laptop is
now another russia russia russia hoax
that's exactly what
this is exactly what this is where he's
going the laptop
is russia russia i want to stay on the
issue of race you have to be kidding me
here we go again with
russia we're going to continue on the
issue of race mr president you've
described the black lives matter
movement as a symbol of hate
you've shared a video of a man chanting
white power to millions of your
supporters
you've said that black professional
athletes exercising their first
amendment rights should be fired
what do you say to americans who say
that kind of language from a president
is contributing to a climate of hate and
racial strife well you have to
understand the first time i ever heard
of black lives matter
they were chanting pigs in a blanket
talking about police pigs
pigs talking about our police pigs in a
blanket fry them
like bacon i said that's a horrible
thing and they were marching down the
street
and that was my first uh glimpse of
black lives matter i thought it was a
terrible thing
as far as my relationships with
all people i think i have great
relationships with all people
i am the least racist person in this
room
what do you say to americans who are
concerned by that rhetoric i don't
mean i don't know what to say i got
criminal justice reform done and prison
reform and opportunity zones i took care
of black
colleges and universities i don't know
what to say
they can say anything i mean they can
say anything
it's a very it's makes me sad because i
am
i i am the least racist person i can't
even see the audience
because it's so dark but i don't care
who's in the audience i'm the least
racist person in this room okay vice
president biden let me ask you
very quickly and then i have a follow-up
question for you abraham lincoln here is
one of the most racist presidents we've
had in modern history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one started off
his campaign coming down the escalator
saying he's getting rid of those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse across the board
he says to them about the poor boys last
time we were on
stage where he said i told him to stand
down and stand ready
come on this guy is a dog whistle about
as big as a foghorn
president trump i'm going to give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have a
phone he
made a reference to abraham lincoln
where did that come in i mean you said
abraham line where did that no no you
said i said
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done what i've done for the black
community and i'm gonna say i'm abraham
lincoln i said
not since abraham lincoln has anybody
done what i've done for the black
community now you have done nothing
other than the crime bill
which put oh god that tens of thousands
of black men mostly in jail
all right you know what yeah they
remember you look at what's happening
with the voting right now
let me ask you they remember president i
treated them very very badly
just take a look at what's happening out
there vice president biden let me give
you a chance to respond within this
context crime bills that you supported
in the 80s and 90s
contributed to the incarceration of tens
of thousands of young black men
who had small amounts of drugs in their
possession they are sons they are
brothers their fathers their
uncles whose families are still to this
day some of them
suffering the consequences so speak to
those families why should they vote for
you
one of the things is that in the 80s we
passed
100 all 100 senators voted for it
a bill on drugs and how to deal with
drugs it was a mistake
i've been trying to change the since
then particularly the portion on cocaine
that's why i've been arguing that in
fact we should not
send anyone to jail for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
across the board that's what we should
be spending money that's why i set up
drug courts which were never funded
by republican friends they should not be
going to jail
for a drug or an alcohol problem they
should be going into
treatment treatment that's what we've
been trying to do
that's what i'm going to get done
because i think may the american people
have
now seen that in fact it was a mistake
to pass those laws relating to the drug
but they were not in the crime bill
but why didn't he get it done see it's
all talk no action with his politicians
why didn't he get it then that's what
i'm going to do when i become president
you were vice president along with obama
as your president your leader
for eight years why didn't you get it
done you had eight years to get it done
now you're saying you're going to get it
done because you're all talk and no
action
we got a lot of it done we released 38
did anything got 38
000 prisoners left you got nothing done
38 000 prisoners were released from
federal prison
we have there were over a thousand
people who were given clemency
we make fact we're the ones that put in
the legislation saying
we could look at pattern and practice of
police departments and what they were
doing how they were conducting
themselves
i could go on but we began the process
we began the process
we lost an election that's why i'm
running to win back that election and
change his terrible policies
why didn't you do it in the eight years
a short time ago
why didn't you do it you just said i'm
going to do that i'm going to do this
you put tens of thousands of mostly
black young men in prison now you're
saying you're gonna get
you're gonna undo that why didn't you
get it done you had eight years with
obama
you know why joe because you're all talk
and no action all right vice president
biden and then we're gonna move on to
the next section
better republican congress
that's the answer okay you got to talk
them into it
all right you got to talk them into it
we're going to move on to our next
section like i did with
criminal justice reform i had to talk
democrats into
gentlemen we're running out of time so
we've got to get on to
climate change please you both have very
different visions on climate change
president trump you say that
environmental regulations have hurt jobs
in the energy sector
vice president biden you have said you
see addressing climate change
as an opportunity to create new jobs for
each of you
how would you both combat climate change
and support job growth at the same time
starting with you president trump
you have two minutes uninterrupted so we
have the trillion trees program
we have so many different programs i do
love the environment but what i want is
the cleanest
crystal clear water the cleanest air we
have the best lowest number
in carbon emissions which is a big
standard that i notice
obama goes with all the time not joe i
haven't heard joe use the term because
i'm not sure he knows what it represents
or means but i have heard obama use it
and we have the best carbon emission
numbers that we've had in 35 years
under this administration we are working
so well with industry but here's what we
can't do
look at china how filthy it is look at
russia look at india it's
filthy the the air is filthy
the paris accord i took us out because
we were going to have to spend
trillions of dollars and we were treated
very unfairly
when they put us in there they did us a
great disservice they were going to take
away our businesses
i will not sacrifice tens of millions of
jobs
thousands and thousands of companies
because of
the paris accord it was so unfair china
doesn't kick
in until 2030. russia goes back to a low
standard
and we kicked in right away it would
have been
it would have been it would have
destroyed our businesses so
you ready we have done an incredible job
environmentally
we have the cleanest air the cleanest
water and the best carbon emission
standards
that we've seen in many many years vice
president
we haven't destroyed our industries vice
president biden two minutes to you
uninterrupted climate change and climate
warming
global warming is an existential threat
to humanity
we have a moral obligation to deal with
it
and we're told by all the leading
scientists in the world we don't have
much time we're going to pass the point
of no return
within the next eight to ten years four
more years of this man
eliminating all the regulations that
were put in by us
to clean up the climate to clean up to
limit
the the uh limited emissions will put us
in a position where we're going to be in
real
trouble here's where we have a great
opportunity i was able to get both
all the environmental organizations as
well as labor the people worried about
jobs
to support my climate plan because what
it does
it will create millions of new good
paying jobs
we're going to invest in for example 500
000 50 000 50 000 charging stations
on our highways so that we can own the
electric car market of the future
in the meantime china is doing that
we're going to be in a position where
we're going to see to it
that we're going to take 4 million
existing billions
buildings and 2 million existing homes
and retrofit them so they don't leak as
much energy
saving hundreds of millions of barrels
of oil
in the process and creating significant
number of jobs
and by the way the whole idea of what
this is all going to do it's going to
create
millions of jobs and it's going to clean
the environment our health
and our jobs are at stake that's what's
happening
and what right now by the way wall
street firms indicated that
my plan my my plan will in fact create
18.6 million jobs seven million more
than his this is from wall street
and i'll create one trillion dollars
more in economic growth
than his proposal does not on climate
just on the economy
president trump came out and said very
strongly
six thousand five hundred dollars will
be taken away from families under his
plan
that his plan is an economic disaster if
you look at what he wants to do you know
the
if you look at his plan his
environmental plan you know who
developed it
aoc plus three they know nothing
about the climate i mean she's got a
good line of stuff but she knows nothing
about the climate
and they're all hopping through hoops
for aoc plus three
look their real plan cost a hundred
trillion dollars
if we had the best year in the history
of our country for a hundred years
we would not even come close to a number
like that
when he says buildings they want to take
buildings down because i want to make
bigger windows into smaller windows
as far as they're concerned if you had
no window it would be a lovely thing
this is the craziest plan that anybody
has ever seen
and this wasn't done by smart people
this wasn't done
by anybody frankly i don't even know how
it can be good politically
they want to spend a hundred trillion
dollars that's their real number he's
trying to say it was six
it's a hundred trillion dollars they
want to knock down buildings and build
new buildings with little
tiny small windows i mean and many other
things
and many other things let me have the
vice president respond and we're running
out of time and we have a lot more
questions so let's hear from the vice
president i have a number of more
questions i don't know where he comes
from
i don't know where he comes up with
these numbers we need 100
trillion dollars give me a break
this plan was this is planned endorsed
by every major
every major environmental group and
every labor group
labor because they know the future lies
the future lies and thus being able to
breathe and they know their good jobs in
getting us there
and by the way the fastest growing
industry in america
are is is is the electric
the excuse me solar energy and wind
he thinks wind causes cancer windmills
it's the fastest growing
jobs and they pay good prevailing wages
45-50 bucks an hour
we can grow and we can be cleaner
if we go the route i'm proposing
president trump
for the first time we don't need all of
these countries that we had to fight war
over because we needed their energy
we are energy independent i know more
about wind than you do
it's extremely expensive kills all the
birds
it's very intermittent it's got a lot of
problems and they happen to make the
windmills in both germany and china
and the fumes coming up if you're a
believer in carbon emission
the fumes coming up to make make these
massive windmills
is more than anything that we're talking
about with natural gas which is very
clean one other thing
find me a solar system i love solar but
solar doesn't quite have it yet
it's not powerful yet to to really run
our big
beautiful factories that we need to
compete with the world
so far it's all a pipe dream but you
know what we'll do
we're going to have the greatest economy
in the world but if you want to kill the
economy
get rid of your oil industry you want
and and what about fracking all right
let me know let me have you let me allow
vice president
to respond never said i oppose frackie
you said it on tape i did show the tape
put it on your website i'll put it on
put it on the website the fact of the
matter
is she's flat lying would you rule out
banning fracking
i do rule out benny fracking because the
answer we need
we need other industries
to transition to get to ultimately a
complete
zero emissions by 2025. what i will do
with fracking over time
is make sure that we can capture the
emissions
from the fracking capture the emissions
from gas
we can do that and we can do that by
investing money
and doing it but it's a transition to
that i have one more question in this
position
he was against fracking he said it i
will show that to you tomorrow
i am against fracking until he got the
nomination went to pennsylvania
then he said but you know what
pennsylvania he'll be against it very
soon because his party
is totally against fracking on federal
land i said no
fracking news or oil on february let me
ask this final question
in this section and then i want to move
on to our final
section president trump people of color
are much more likely to live near oil
refineries and chemical plants
in texas there are families who worry
the plants near them are making them
sick
your administration has rolled back
regulations on these kinds of facilities
why should these families give you
another four years in office
the families that we're talking about
are employed heavily and they're making
a lot of money more money than they've
ever made
if you look at the kind of numbers that
we produce for hispanic
or black for asian it's nine times
greater the percentage gain
than it was under in three years than it
was under
eight years of the two of them
to put it nicely nine times more
now somebody lives i have not heard the
numbers or the stats
statistics that you're saying but
they're making a tremendous amount of
money
economically we saved it and i saved it
again a number of months ago when oil
was crashing because of the pandemic
we saved it we got say what you want
about relationship we got saudi arabia
mexico and russia to cut back way back
we saved our oil industry
and now it's very vibrant together and
everybody has very inexpensive gasoline
vice president biden your response and
then we're going to have a final
question for both of you
my response is that those people live on
what they call fence lines he doesn't
understand this
they live near chemical plants that in
fact pollute
chemical plants and oil plants and
refineries to pollute
i used to live near that when i was
growing up in clemont delaware
and all the more oral refineries in
marcus hook in the delaware river than
there is
any place including in houston at the
time when my mom get in the car and when
when her first frost to drive me to
school turned in the windshield with an
oil slick in the window
that's why so many people in my state
were dying and getting cancer
the fact is those front-line communities
this doesn't matter what you're paying
them it matters
how you keep them safe what do you do
and you impose restrictions on the
pollutions
that the pollutants coming out of those
fence line
communities okay i have one final would
he close down the island
it falls or would you close down the
earth by the way i have a transition
from the oil industry yes
oh transition it is a big statement
because i would stop why would you do
that because
the oil industry pollutes significantly
i said here's the deal but that's a big
statement well if you let me finish the
statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
he won't give federal subsidies to the
to the gas which excuse me to the
uh to uh solar and wind yeah why are we
giving it to oil industry
we actually do solar and wind that's
maybe the biggest statement in terms of
business
that's the biggest thing okay because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
pennsylvania oklahoma vice president
biden let me give you 10 seconds to
respond and then i have to get to the
final question vice president biden
he takes everything out of context but
the point is look
we have to move toward a net zero
emissions
the first place to do that by the year
2035 is in energy production
by 2050 totally all right is he gonna
get china to do it no we're finished
with it is he going to get china's
final question we have i'm going to
rejoin parish the court to make
china abide by what they agreed to all
right
leadership gentlemen and this first
question
does go to you president trump imagine
this is your inauguration day
what will you say in your address to
america to americans who did not
vote for you you'll each have one minute
starting with you
we have to make a country totally
successful as it was prior to the plague
coming in from china
now we're rebuilding it and we're doing
record numbers 11.4 million jobs in a
short period of time etc but i will tell
you go back
before the plague came in just before i
was getting calls from people that were
not normally people that would call me
they wanted to get together we had the
best
black unemployment numbers in the
history of our country
hispanic women asian
people with diplomas with no diplomas
mit graduates number one in the class
everybody had the best numbers and you
know what the other side
wanted to get together they wanted to
unify success is going to bring us
together
we are on the road to success but i'm
cutting taxes
and he wants to raise everybody's taxes
and he wants to put new regulations on
everything
he will kill it if he gets in you will
have a depression the likes of which
you've never seen
your 401ks will go to hell and it'll be
a very very sad day for this country
all right vice president biden same
question to you what will you say
during your inaugural address to
americans who did not vote for you
i will say i'm an american president
i represent all of you whether you voted
for me or against me
and i'm going to make sure that you're
represented i'm going to give you hope
we're going to move we're going to
choose science over fiction
we're going to choose hope over fear
we're going to choose to move forward
because they have enormous
opportunities enormous opportunities to
make things better
we can grow this economy we can deal
with systemic racism
at the same time we can make sure that
our economy
is being run and moved and motivated by
clean energy creating millions of new
jobs
and that's the fact that's what we're
going to do and i'm going to say
as i said in the beginning what is on
the ballot here
is the character of this country decency
honor respect treating people with
dignity
making sure that everyone has an even
chance and i'm going to make sure you
get that
you haven't been getting in the last
four years all right
i want to thank you both for a very
robust hour and a half a fantastic
debate
really appreciate it president trump
former vice president joe biden
thank you to belmont university for
hosting us tonight and most importantly
thank you to those watching tonight
election day is november 3rd
don't forget to vote thank you everyone
and have a great night
so